it's a lot about Focus having a clear
mind and just just focus on that one
target that one in front of
[Applause]
you you can hit the target no matter
what because it it only moves so many
directions but what really patches you
is when you start thinking too much and
getting ahead of yourself
so many times you find you know kids
that are on sports teams that spend all
the time sitting on the bench there's no
Benchwarmers here there is no second
string kids everybody shoots everybody
competes my name is Roland Thompson and
I'm a sophomore at burlon Edison High
School I've been shooting competitively
for about four years now my name is
Sophie I'm a senior at Cy High School
there's about around 13 teams here that
are competing for the top school in our
district I'm David Bradbury I am the
head coach of the Newport High School
Klay Target team we we have a our local
gun club and in recent years it's really
struggled because ammunition costs are
going through the roof uh targets are
expensive we do not have a significant
number of of community members as part
of our club under the age of 50 our club
membership has significantly decreased
uh the club that I grew up in the 80s
that had 100 plus um participants
members uh now we're down to 30 or 40 a
gentleman part of our club he approached
me and said you know Dave if if we don't
do something to get the younger
generation involved and younger families
involved our club and our Shooting
Sports around here they're going to die
literally he suggested that we follow
the lead of a school that is about an
hour and a half north of us right close
to the Canadian border they had started
a clay target team and so we followed
their lead we did the same thing and the
first year we only had five or six or
seven kids the next year we had 10 or 12
the next year we had 20 last year we had
35 this year we're hoping to have 40
plus hi my name is John Nelson I am the
president of the USA clay target League
the history with the league really
started with the problems in the hunting
and shooting sport Community that's
really has been um happening over the
past 30 to 40 years with declining
participation in both of those Sports
and so when the founder of the program
named Jim Sable and I used to work
together he started looking at his local
Club wondering why there isn't any kids
participating at his Club because he was
one of the younger me members at the age
of 60 and so Jim had the concept of
saying is hey how do we make clay target
a school sponsored sport as you can
imagine in our early days we struggled
with trying to go to schools and trying
to say hey we have a great sport that
all your kids should participate in and
everyone can be included and it doesn't
matter what gender you are your physical
capabilities and you don't have to be
the tallest and the fastest and the
strongest and all these great things
that we could do and then we would say
andle by the way it involves a gun and
so we had an awful lot of doors closed
on us right when we told them about you
know that it involves the shotgun but
eventually through proof of performance
in in our safety record and when you
compare it against other high school
sports is a lot of Administrators at the
school level really could see the safety
practices that we have in place that
really make this sport the safest sport
in high school and so so from there we
started to not only increase the number
of kids participating in the sport here
in our home state of Minnesota but then
we had other states nearby that wanted
to join the party we have about 34 State
High School clay target leagues we have
two College clay target leagues and we
also have a homeschool clay target
league and so collectively uh this year
we hosted over 49,000 student athletes
that were on over 1,600 teams now it is
so much easier to go to the schools with
1,600 plus other teams behind you that
are saying hey this league has never had
an injury and no other sport in high
school can say
that I mean you got a hundred kids here
walking around with guns and there's not
a worry in the world about their
abilities you know every one of these
kids is is second nature to them I
really like the the environment that
trap offers it's kind of cool to get to
do a sport like this since I mean a lot
of of times school and stuff is pretty
taboo against guns but I think that it
is really nice to have high schoolers
able to use guns and get comfortable
with the usage of them so that they can
go out into the world not having a fear
of them we have a lot of support we have
a a lot of people that um groups that
sponsor the kids for their for shooting
and shoot and sponsor the shells and
sponsor sweatshirts and all kinds of
stuff to support the kids and their
endeavors and we've had groups try to
shut us down yeah we have uh I've been
through that before too like you know
guns don't belong to schools and uh
Burlington Edison it doesn't belong
shooting so I over the almost 30 years
I've seen it
all all of these efforts have started
with moms and dads and a couple teachers
who have said we we need to be proactive
about this and let's get something
established and get the ball rolling
largely a Grassroots effort for folks
who are are in a generation similar to
mine who grew up experiencing and
enjoying certain things that in today's
environment um are becoming more and
more restrictive if there's not a
proactive effort to embrace and
encourage and reestablish so many of
these awesome things they'll they'll
dwindle
away I think it shapes how I've like how
hard I work how like cuz I have I put a
lot of time and hours into shooting
dedication I think that's definitely
branched out from just shooting into
like my life working hard and getting it
done a lot of it's just just that
determination you to stay with them you
know you can miss that first Target but
you got to shoot the next 24 you know
and you might want to shoot a 100 and
you miss the first to the second ones
but you have to reach deep and continue
to work for every single one of them you
can't just give up so it's that
determination that mental you know
awareness the the concentration you know
you got to beat yourself you got to beat
yourself physically you got to beat
yourself mentally you got to beat the
guy next to
you you know you just you just keep keep
trying keep plugging away at it over and
over and over again to get that one more
[Music]
Target